start jetzt muss man muss das auch auf
youtube
jetzt muss noch wirklich live sein
glaube ich okay doch wird gestartet
ich bin halt oder hallo was geht heute
sondern können wir das hier mal weg
machen leute
herzlich willkommen zu einem live stream
dem ersten live stream den ich seit
gefühlt 30.000 jahren gemacht habe auf
youtube heute denn es gibt ein
besonderes ereignis
guck dir mal den chat alle kommen wir da
rein es geht ja leute was geht
mama nicht geschrieben hat wird
wahrscheinlich gestrigen rechtsbeistand
ja was machen wir heute wir leute haben
heute eine mission von 255 und die die
man kann aber schon eine weile verfolgen
wissen dass ich öfter mal so mich mit
baby beschäftigt habe und jetzt gerade
sbb ja wieder ganz groß quasi im trend
warum es mir jetzt auch schon wissen
kann ihm weiß man nicht du kannst auf
dem handy mal nach den cha cha und
theoretisch ja und leute ihr habt es
vielleicht gesehen wie wir hatten mega
viele oder zwei ankündigung gemacht so
mysteriöse und man weiß nicht genau was
da passiert ist mir viele leute
entwickeln der theorie ist sie schwanger
keine ahnung haben mich schon geheiratet
nein ich weiß auch nicht ob dieses
überhaupt verlobt haben wir nicht
bekommen habe oder ob sie jetzt oder ob
das fahrzeug wird die theorie von sarah
desiderio dass die neues zwölf das
bioprodukt rausbringt aber dann haben
wir auch da haben wir was zu lachen aber
ich glaube die anzahl jetzt habe ich
ganz ehrlich
der hat schon so viele bioprodukte
rausgebracht warum in aller welt sollte
sie so ein hype um einfach ein weiteres
machen
entweder ist irgendwas komplett neues
raus so ist schwanger glaube ich
persönlich nicht ich oder mein großer
tipps geben um neue saison ja ja ich
glaube wirklich könnten neuen song geben
bei babys mit der ansage und mit dem ja
mit dem mit dem einfachheit der
aufgebaut wurde
leute das wird das würde krank werden
der letzte song hat glaube ich vier
millionen discs 50 millionen views viele
legal aber kein scheich vier million des
lecks doch ich hätte ja auch 3 oder so
aber gucken
schau mal findet man ist man hier runter
scrollen wie kriegen euch eure übrigens
eure kommentare rheinfahrt jetzt eben
klein geschrieben haben soll es mal die
ganze zeit kommen gleich rein und wir
können auch reagieren ok 3200
live-zuschauer stabiler als alkohol das
ist eine gute zahlen danke dass ihr am
start zeitweilig ps ich sehe gerade im
livestream dass ich ein bisschen weiter
über muss sich also jetzt hat diese
kultur wir leute das ist alles sehr
profitiert wir sind bei unserer familie
nach aschaffenburg wir wollen eigentlich
in köln
und da haben wir so ein livestream setup
auf einem monitor es ist alles sehr
seltsam mit so drei jahre alt mikrofon
habe leute gewinnen zeit ist auch da
schreibt jemand gerade eben schreibt
jemand die heiraten am 12 05 können wir
jetzt nicht verifizieren hallo baby
schreit haha ja okay was schon weiter
wahnsinn was für für richtiger schritt
gerade jemand sie ist schwanger sind um
23 59 ein ultraschallbild gepostet und
es dann gelöscht
ja es ist also der ist nicht wahr aber
weiter das wird richtig heftig da kann
man hier um 2,7 millionen des lecks mit
hilfe aufgesucht
leute ich hab euch das video natürlich
nicht geht es leichter haben jetzt ganz
kurz mal eine anzeige fehler sorry dafür
auf jeden fall ja das geht nicht so ab
aber du bist ja sozusagen baby experte
weil es den damals aber ja also zu
diesem sommer habe ich ein paar gemacht
das war teilweise bis in gut ich war
nicht so gemein da drin aber man muss
gucken dass man auch das alles mit spaß
macht und das ist nicht persönlich wird
aber ganz ehrlich man muss auch dazu
sagen sollte jetzt noch dazu komme ich
noch nicht gesehen haben ich bin doch
kein baby stalker oder so also für feld
gehört jetzt einer denkt sich so was ist
bei dem das ist also ich habe mich so
spaß an reagans und die nächste kommt
gleich dann ist es 11 8 400 man muss
natürlich sagen das ist ein super
spannendes und greifsysteme auf youtube
klarer und sebastians dinge sind so
reactions kommentare und klar das hat
ein am start das ist einfach auf
abreagieren
hier steht das ding ist einfach ist
interessiert doch keinen ob sie
schwanger heiratet ist das ist ihr leben
und mich juckt ist nicht alles
so ein haus dazu muss man sagen kann
sich die man teilen kann
aber sie ist nun auch eine person des
öffentlichen lebens und glaubt mir dass
sie sich sicherlich nicht darüber
aufregt wenn jemand hier so ein
livestream macht sondern ist es genau
das was sie was sie möchte sie hat zwei
videos hochgeladen und hype zu
generieren und alles im dunkeln gelassen
also ich glaub baby stört das nicht und
wir haben auch spaß dabei sind gespannt
das ist halt einfach auf youtube youtube
sind halt auch so dumme sachen einfach
wie keine ahnung millionen menschen
schauen baden in videos also diesmal
hält oder zehn millionen menschen gucken
an wie jemand 24 stunden lang fort sagt
gehört auch vor leute kommt auch vor
nämlich vielen dingen sein
ich fühle mich jetzt im online ticket
kaufen und also brauche ich auch dass
ich war geweckt wird so hat sie gar
nein das stimmt schon länger aber gleich
ist soweit zwölfter fünfter 12 uhr okay
ich ja und ja leute wir haben nichts
besseres zu nicht umsonst wirklich fest
was glaubst du kommt ich sag's kommen
song ich sage es kommt es kommt auf
jeden fall einen song ab ich bin gesagt
okay wir genau wollten mag es gerade
aufgestanden sei dank konnte ich bin
nicht gerade bescheiden aber ich habe
mich aus dem bett bewegt ist nicht
rangers oh ja da ist was es heißt
changes herz und okay wir haben einen
kopfhörer durch das einschalten und wann
ich rate mal in die in die comments oder
willst du anderen nehmen hatte ich habe
meinen chat alter youtube.com ich
hinterher youtube okay okay es ist ein
song 6000 likes
oder oder hatten die mein gott mein herz
schlagen einige ich habe deswegen habe
ich gesagt ganz vorsichtig was man sagen
was man vorher sagt weil wenn die
wirklich schwanger ist aber warte mal
als ich das video megaschön oder also
das ist echt ja es war ein winzer und
thematischer kampagne jetzt so unser
neues unser neues natürlich ist shampoo
als kind schwanger ist ach du scheiße
sie war schwanger schwaiger schwaiger
alle rassen auf teurer als glaube
wirklich oder manches meisten sie tragen
auch noch im eigentlichen wieder krank
aber es gab auch kommentare die im
ultraschallbild gesehen haben wollen im
ersten video was hochgeladen werde so
ihre leute warum hat mich das jetzt ist
es sofort über aber das halt das ist
radikal schalter ohne spaß
das versteht die generation vor uns
nicht die generation nach uns wird
wahrscheinlich auch nicht verstehen das
ist schon irgendwie
[Musik]
aber ich muss eigentlich dass es auch
gab eine ganz andere stimmung das ist
nicht wieso überhaupt des songs sind so
sondern das ist wie
interessant jetzt geht's gleich mal so
um zur kamera sowie house of cards und
heben die lupe
wir haben das kind bekommen kann sagt
der hat dieses anders gut 40
ob es davon - geben oder allgemeines
jetzt kommen kommt überhaupt was warte
warte jetzt laufen irgendwo hin locker
hinter diesem berg kommt irgendwas oder
war gerade was locker legten kind ist da
war gerade was wirklich machen na das
ist ja mal sowas von instagram dieses
ganze wie immer diese kissen namen alter
das schreiben alle heiraten
sie ist schwanger
[Musik]
jülich
sonst wurden gigantische fällt jetzt
jetzt mal einfach so eine wolke von
seinem kind eine dämmung eingebaut
ok dafür dass endlich offiziell
bestätigt krank krank alter damit das
hätte ich nicht gedacht dass wir
brauchen das muss man sagen aber klar
wir wissen aber krass alter heftig das
finde ich wirklich cool was ich sagen
mega schönes video war also wirklich an
der stelle kann man nur ja man kann nur
herzlich gratulieren ich wünsche euch
ich wünsche euch ich wünsche euch das
beste das auch dass ihr großartige
eltern werden naja wurde wird dabei also
man muss auch mal trennen zwischen so ja
immer ein bisschen alt war und wir alle
drücken sie mal gegenseitig einspruch
reinemachen es durch übereinander
aber so wie das aussieht ist sie
wirklich schwanger und das ist ein sehr
großes event im leben von der menschen
und da kann man wirklich nur zu
gratulieren und wie viel sie für die
typen mamas kennst du ja das geht es
gibt schon ein paar mal was aber so aber
so auch so sowie von den top ten in
deutschland so finde ich aber auch
schade dass geht will ich hoffen wir die
leute gucken sich ja an weil ich hoffe
ich sowas
so was gehört einfach nicht gibt es laut
0 kommentare das ist unsinnig oder das
239.000 alter wir haben vier minuten
krank also ja ich weiß ich kann es ja
doch noch mal wiederholen herzlichen
glückwunsch auf jeden fall von mir
ich wünsche euch das beste ich hatte
nicht damit gerechnet ehrlich gesagt ich
hätte das wäre mir so ein promo move
weißt du also wird auch wirklich was wo
man keine ahnung irgendwie neues produkt
oder song oder sowas kommt aber sehr
schönes videos das ist sehr schön
gedreht und ja ich würde sagen gibt es
noch viel zu sagen kommentare haben wir
nicht ja lass uns ein bisschen
kommentieren als ich finde es gibt auf
jeden fall ja noch mal checken dass wir
im bild sind ist nicht ganz
professionell leute bestimmt nicht so
oft ich würde wirklich sagen es ist mal
es ist eine schöne andere seite
irgendwie das ist so 40
also ja also das man muss sich wie
gesagt immer ein bisschen noch klar
machen so das ist halt immer noch
youtube das ist spaß und niemand als ich
kenne ganz ganz wenige leute die
wirklich sagen ich hasse den anderen
youtuber und ja also baby definitiv
nicht ja und ja leute scheinbar ist baby
schwanger noch mal sehr schön das video
schön gemacht
jesus jesus man sehr gut das hätte sony
dies funktioniert ich bezweifle heftig
alter ist in lässt ist es voll der
baby-boom alter mann kriegt sofort alle
kardashians werden schwanger baby wird
schwanger das ist eine baby-party
heiraten leute es krank soll auch ein
bild machen was machen leute wenn wir
mehr machen sollen dann gebe ich ihm
eine backpfeife mit der linken hand
wir verabschieden uns so weit von dieser
kurzen lektionen an diesem samstag
wir hoffen ihr hattet über die
unterhaltung dabei unseren spaß gemacht
auf jeden fall schon gerne bei den video
vorbei lasst den leiterrahmen glück und
nicht deswegen schreibt irgend kommentar
wenn die kommentare geöffnet werden ich
glaube steht nun ja leute wieder ins
haus bringt wir sind sagt mir einfach
vor sich
wir können da was aushandelt